Brain trauma from that fight.
There is a,
I don't want to say there's a rash of suicides in the seal teams specifically.
Obviously the number 22 is thrown out a lot when it comes to veterans suicides.
But that's what does a 22%,
22 veterans a day a convinced he said is the number that is often touted.
I,
I'm hesitant to say that number is accurate because if you look at how it was
derived,
it wasn't,
they could have done a better job of getting that number.
And I,
and I don't want to say inside of the seal teams if there's a suicide issue,
even though I do know a few people that have committed suicide and they were the
ones that I would least expect it from,
but they were also the ones who had,
uh,
quite a bit of a high operational tempo.
And the one thing that I don't think,
especially in the military medicine world,
they understand well as traumatic brain injury and the impact it has long term
and how easy it can be.
Because you know this,
uh,
I've heard you talk about it before,
you don't have to get knocked out to get a brain injury.
Right.
And I know countless times where I either did something dumb or was just
standing in the wrong place or had a hard parachute opening and I cracked my
head against the metal risers and your head hurts for the rest of the day.
Yeah.
And it's,
I've seen the change in behavior in some people and I,
I know the stuff that's tied to it as well,
the low hormones,
all of that stuff there that is happening I think at the highest levels in the
military,
probably military wide,
but specifically those people who were kind of more on the front leading edge of
combat operations.
And I think as a country we're in a word,
a total unknown area because we're in a sustained period of war longer we've
ever been as a nation and nobody knows the outcome of that.
And people who I would've never guessed would make the decision to take their
own life.
I'll get a text and hey,
you know,
so and so just went out into the woods and no other external injury,
no other marker.
Then obviously something happened in the geometry between their ears that caused
them to make that decision.
And I suspect it's from the repeated exposure to the brain injury.
Yeah.
It's something that people are just starting to understand over the last couple
of decades.
I mean obviously a,
there was a focus that concussion movie and you know,
I don't know if you saw that Bob Costas was actually pulled from football.
Uh,
and they,
they had told him that he'd crossed the line,
the announcer,
they pulled him,
they pulled him from doing,
uh,
what,
what event was it?
Was it from the Superbowl because,
uh,
he was talking about traumatic brain injury and the realities of it and they
said,
you crossed the line.
He's like,
I crossed the line by talking about reality,
honest and open person.
That's not cool.
I mean,
that's what he does.
that is Bob Costas,
his entire hook.
But I mean,
he's,
he's a brilliant guy.
But this,
uh,
this problem was so poorly understood just two decades ago.
So everyone's just sort of coming to this realization that,
I mean,
according to Dr. Mark Gordon,
who have,
I've had on who works with the Warrior Angel Foundation,
Andrew Mars,
uh,
set up where they're helping all these veterans that have traumatic brain
injuries.
And I've,
I've had Mr. Gordon on several times.
He says that you can get traumatic brain injuries from things that don't even
remotely knock you out.
He was like,
people get them from doing moguls when they ski.
They get them from,
from your brain,
just Rad and get them from jet skis bouncing around on jet skis.
I mean,
you can get it from a minor car accident.
You can have a traumatic brain injury.
And for guys like me that got hit in the head for years,
who knows what the fuck is going on in there.
You know?
And for professional fighters,
it's,
you know,
it's almost inevitable for football players.
It's even worse,
you know,
for football players,
they did some crazy study and I know we quoted it and I don't remember what the
numbers was,
but at some insane number,
like in the high 80% of people from high school on through college and into the
professionals have Tbi or CTE or the some signs of a traumatic brain injury.
I'd be surprised if they didn't give them.
They're fucking crazy.
It gets,
it is interesting too,
like I was saying,
so when I got medically retired,
they sent me to a medical facility called Nikko,
which is attached to Walter Reed and as the best care that I ever received
because it's a civilian facility.
It's called the national intrepid center of excellence.
We did a lot of work with them back in the day for the UFC.
The UFC raised a bunch of money for that.
Really?
Yeah.
Well,
the money was well spent because I went there and I probably would not have been
medically retired had I not because I left with literally 150 page dossier and,
but it's interesting tying it back to Tbi because I spent a lot of time as a
requirement talking to psychologists and psychiatrists and it the Tbi pts in the
military.
It gets interesting because it seems like they're treated as different issues.
And I'm probably misquoting the number a little bit.
I think there's 13 recognize symptoms of both,
but there's an overlay of like 11 so,
uh,
I can't remember any of these symptoms off the top of my head,
but you could describe one and it could apply both to Tbi and post traumatic
stress.
So it gets even more muddled on how are you treating somebody for a brain injury
or are you treating somebody for a post traumatic stress?
Are you lumping everybody together?
It's just cause I see a lot of people and specifically a lot of veterans getting
stuck in that world where they've,
it's a lot of focus on pts,
but the reality is it could just be from the trauma received over a career or
you know,
nearly two decades for most people to make it to retirement.
It's
Intel.
Well apparently blasts are a big one,
right?
Like blown down doors and things like that.
Even even you just step away and you brace yourself.
The impact of just the air,
the concussive force of it,
this is devastating for your brain.
The human brain apparently is just so much more delicate and sensitive than
anyone could have ever guessed will.
And concussive blasts
are tough phone because they travel.
So if you're internally in a building and you find a door that's at the end of a
hallway,
even if you go all the way down to the end of the hallway and around the corner
of the blast can still get you,
cause it will come down off the door,
reflect off of the hallway and still rocky you,
Jesus.
Yeah,
it's,
I thought I had a good hiding spot more than once.
Did not have a good,
had you sit in and just be like,
oh that hurt.
Oh,
more than one occasion.
Or you're working with a bunch of assholes who take all the good hiding spots.
I kind of DM it has turned around and just ball up and there's not really much
you can do about that.
Right?
I mean if you have to blow down that door,
someone has to be there to detonate and you have to be close enough for it to
activate.
Right.
Uh,
how are they doing it wirelessly?
They might be doing it wirelessly.
Now when I was in,
uh,
it was called known l,
um,
and it basically,
it's a or a shock tube.
So you put a charge wherever adult,
uh,
a gate,
a door and you basically have to attach an initiator to it cause the charge
isn't going to go off by itself.
So you need a highly reactive charge to set off an explosive that has less
reactive.
You keep them separate,
obviously for safety,
except for the main breach.
He probably has at least one hooked up so he can be really fast.
But then you just extend that flash tube and it's,
they come in long reels.
I mean that you can get 30,
40,
50 feet and each charge,
mathematically we do math on it to determine the minimum safe distance of every
charge.
And it's written on the charge.
So you know how far you can get away.
But sometimes you're in a situation where,
like I said,
that you think you got an awesome hiding spot and the guy lays out the flash
tube and he's getting ready to fire it off and you realize that you're staring
directly at the charge and you have nowhere to hide and they're not going to
wait on you.
So it's turn around,
cover up into a ball and eat it.
Oh,
this is there a best way to eat it?
A open your mouth and cover your ears.
I'm Aly.
Yeah,
open your mouth yet.
Allow instance instead of overloading,
uh,
like your sinus cavities and your,
your ear canal so we can cover ears and open your mouth.
It helps if something's going to go off really close to you.
Open your mouth and cover your ears.
Yup.
What,
what,
what's the difference between opening and closing the mouth?
Uh,
the effect of the wave.
Am I understanding that contain pressure inside of your body as opposed to
giving it a,
an avenue to escape Jesus Christ?
One of the things they're realizing apparently about concussions is that even
just getting hit in the chest can give you concussion from the tip of the head.
Cause you're,
you know,
you get hit in the chest and you're like,
I didn't even get hit in the head,
but just getting hit in the chest makes your head snap and it makes your brain
swish around inside your head.
And that's what gives you an injury.
I just remember earlier on,
I mean like in the mid two thousands it wasn't,
the only question was does your head hurt?
Like that was the beginning of whether or not you might have sustained a
concussion.
And then obviously learning much more now and where we're at.
It's like,
yeah,
you may have even had any sensation in your head,
but you know,
it's kind of crazy when you think about how long people have been studying the
human body,
and then this is just something they've really got to a real understanding of in
the last couple of decades.
I don't even know if I would characterize it as a real understanding.
I think they're farther along than they were to two decades ago,
but I think the amount we know versus the amount that we don't know is much more
weighted on the amount.
We don't know.